every year proud owners of vintage and
classic cars get together for countless
meets and rallies like the classic days
at dyke palace
they've polished and tinkered all winter
and can hardly wait to hit the road
but all too often vintage car owners
value looks more than safety and tires
are far down the maintenance list but
the tires put the rubber to the road and
take enormous strain often for much
longer than is safe
the potential consequences can be
demonstrated on a test track
porsche regularly puts tires of all
makes through their paces tires for
their newest generations and for the
many older porsches on the road it's the
only car maker to do so
porsche test driver dieter rush eisen
says this car has older tires on it with
only seven millimeters of tread
some think that's enough but it's not
every year a tire loses more traction
that's very noticeable in wet conditions
when the front axle can't hold the car's
direction
in a curve the car goes forward and
can't be steered
the only way to guide the car is to let
up on the gas to regain some control on
the front axle
again
the wide steering angle that results can
lead to disaster if the rear axle loses
traction
the driver won't be able to compensate
through the steering wheel
a wipeout is close to inevitable
and even beyond that as soon as the
driver hits the brakes the wheels lock
older vehicles don't have anti-lock
braking systems so the driver has to be
gentle with the brakes
even then the front axle may still lock
up then the car will skid in the
direction it was going
a tire has to meet the highest standards
to be porsche certified it has to meet
33 criteria 100 percent that applies to
tires for new as well as for older
models
porsche's goals are the greatest
possible customer satisfaction and best
driving experience
porsche approved tires are marked with
an n their website also lists approved
summer and winter tires for both current
and vintage models
the approved tires usually cost about
the same
porsche test driver detox eisen says
once the new tires are on they provide
the needed traction and the car is
noticeably faster
in terms of lap times that means 18
seconds less for 1900 meters on the wet
handling track
the cars are not only faster but safer
too
the traction gives more directional
control to the front axle and the wheels
don't lock up when the driver hits the
brakes
it makes an enormous difference now the
handling is much quicker and more
responsive there's a margin for safety
that wasn't there before
it's good before i light and eat
good tires put the fun back in driving
many vintage car owners only head out in
nice weather if at all
sometimes their tires are years old then
if they take part in a rally or classic
car event and it rains it's a disaster
waiting to happen
all too often the driver only starts
thinking about what should have been
done after the car is in a ditch
to make sure that doesn't happen porsche
recommends new tires every six or seven
years no matter how much tread they have
even with vintage cars safety is the
bottom line